[Music]
like a lot of people i was exposed to
your ted talk do we see reality as it is
and was was struck by the desktop
interface metaphor could you please
just explain that in brief and then we
can take that in a number of of any
directions
the question is how should we understand
our perceptions and the relationship to
reality
most of us
just
assume that we know the answer our
perceptions show us reality
not all of it but when i see the moon
there really is a moon and of course i
don't see everything about the moon but
i see what i need to see when i see a
carrot
i'm seeing the truth i'm seeing the
correct shape the correct color
the correct the weight if i pick it up
and of course i'm not seeing this
molecular structure so they're things i
don't see but but i'm seeing truly if if
incompletely
and
the interface theory of perception
takes a different tack on on what
perception is it says if we take
evolution of a natural selection
seriously
we can ask a technical question
would
evolution by natural selection shape
sensory systems
to
tell truths about the physical world
around us or whatever the world might be
around us that's the technical question
what is the probability
that natural selection would shape
sensory systems to report
true
properties of objective reality
and you can show through theorems and
simulations so my graduate students
working with me on this brian marion
justin mark and uh and others
and some so my colleagues jayton prakash
when you sing and i've been i've worked
on this
robert prentner
a number of us have worked on this and
the simulations and the mathematics
all agree the probability is zero that
natural selection
would shape any sensory system of any
organism
to reveal any true properties of
objective reality it is precisely zero
and
one intuition about that is that fitness
payoff functions we can go into this
later on if we if you want fitness
payoff functions
almost surely
have no information about objective
reality they they're not so called
homomorphisms of structures in objective
reality and so so if we're tuned to
fitness
and the fitness payoffs literally are
not homomorphisms of structures in
reality then there's no way that our
perceptions can be homomorphic to to
reality to
the structures of reality so so what
then
if
we take evolution of natural selection
seriously and i think we should
not because
i'm claiming it's the final story
but it's the best story we have
right science
always
to its credit
gets new theories
and what we thought was the the final
theory 120 years ago we now look back on
it you know newton was great but we have
much better theories today and so i have
the same view about all of our
scientific theories that we have today
the reason i take them seriously is not
because i think they're the final word
it's just that we have as human beings
no better theories and so these are so
we have to take our current theories
seriously and so if we take evolution
for natural selection seriously
of course as scientists we're going to
eventually try to show its limitations
right
but what it says in his current form
is
that the probability is zero that our
senses have shaped us to see the truth
about the world around us so what have
they shaped us to do well the the answer
within evolutionary theory is it's all
about fitness
our sensory systems have shaped us
to
guide adaptive behavior
so we can live long enough to reproduce
basically
and so
one way to put that in a metaphor that's
easier to understand is to say that
natural selection didn't shape us to see
the truth but it shaped us
with sensory systems that are like a
user interface to the truth
so you know right now
we're both sitting in front of
laptops
and
we're able to
i mean i've got
gigabytes of memory and all the
circuitry inside my laptop i have no
idea
about is the truth of that i mean i i
know the words i'm not a you know i'm
not a
engineer of that type so i
so i don't really if i had to toggle
voltages inside my computer to to do
this video with you it wouldn't happen
so if i actually knew the truth and i
had to actually toggle all the bits and
bytes and so forth and voltages in the
computer to make this video happen and
you had to do it
it wouldn't happen we have a very simple
dumbed-down user interface that lets us
control
the complexity of the computer
without
having any expertise in what's really
going on inside and that's what
evolution did for us it gave gave us
simple user interface
that lets us stay alive long enough to
reproduce to interact with reality in
the ways that we need to interact with
it to to stay alive and reproduce
without
having any idea what that reality is
you don't have a need to know so you
don't know and and that's just just the
way it is very few of us know exactly
how the desktop interface on our
computer works and you know when you
drag an icon to the trash can
to delete a file there's a lot of stuff
going on inside there that's involved in
dragging you know in deleting the file
we're blissfully ignorant and that's
what evolution has done it makes us
blissfully ignorant about the nature of
reality
and gives us icons that allow us to
control reality so to be very very clear
space and time
which we typically think of as
fundamental reality
is just the format of our 3d desktop we
have instead of a flat desktop we have a
3d
space-time desktop
and objects in 3d are merely the icons
in our desktop they're they're
not
pointers to objective reality in any
sense there's the colors the shapes the
positions that we see have nothing to do
with true colors and shapes and
objective reality they're just a a nice
format that evolution gave us and that
format is going to vary from species to
species
you